For one that will chop chilies.
And that would be it. Thank you.
Can I get three?
What had the main reason I wanted to come to in and out
because I've been seeing this little bad boy
all over my for you page,
and I've been violently craving it,
even though I have no clue what it tastes like
with all the ketchup.
I got a fine Dutchman
with the grilled onions on the outside.
And then I also got my regular order,
which is just a double double animal style
protein style with chopped chilies.
I'm more excited about the Flying Dutchman,
so I'm gonna start with that.
Do you wanna try it?
Yeah, I'll try it.
This is so hot.
But this is what we're working with.
So good. Holy crap.
How was that?
What do you rate that out of 10?
Six or seven.
That's pretty low.
It's okay. I like it, though.
I don't really like in N out fries,
but I still eat them every time I'm here
cause they're weirdly addicting.
But they taste like cardboard to me.
Yourself or for me?
Um. We can share it. OK,
it's a Flying Dutchman wrapped in whole grilled onions.
Writing it in your notes? Yeah,
well, I'm texting it too,
so I don't forget.
What am I getting?
I'm getting.
He just went in to get some more stuff,
so we're getting another one of those Flying Dutchmen.
He's getting himself his third double
double He also got some milkshakes.
And I think that's it.
In my first trimester,
I was craving in N out so much.
And it's been like that with my other two pregnancies
as well. Like,
I could eat it every single day.
And I. I did.
I ate it a lot.
And now it's not that much of a craving.
I think secretly lucky loves the Flying Dutchmans.
He just doesn't wanna admit it.
But he got us another one
without me having to ask. Ha, ha.
It's the salt on top of the ketchup.
The burger for me.
I'm stuffed.
Do you want the rest?